hey 42 here every single day you
voluntarily give hundreds of data points
to giant multibillion-dollar tech
companies but in the worst possible
scenario imaginable how could all this
data be used against you if some
corporation or perhaps the government
had the motivation to do so
the answer may terrify you but first
let's take a look at a place that is
already using people's data to test the
limits of human rights China China is
run by a communist party and they have
begun to show the world just how
dystopian a country can become in the
digital age you may have already heard
about the Social Credit system currently
being trialed across China the idea has
been around in China since 2001 and it's
expected to be fully operational across
all of mainland China by 2020 affecting
and controlling 1.4 billion people in
case you haven't heard of it here's a
quick lowdown every citizen is given a
social credit score which is similar to
the financial credit scores we have in
the West it ranges from 350 to 950
citizens can increase their social
credit score by doing good deeds such as
reporting crimes giving blood and
carrying out heroic apps whatever the
hell that means but it will get knocked
down if they jaywalk commit crimes are
loud in public or drop cigarette butts
or other litter on the ground but it
gets even scarier the aim is for the
whole system to be automated and China
is working with private companies to
actively develop AI systems that monitor
citizens 24/7 online and offline China
currently has the largest CCTV network
in the world by a large margin with over
200 million cameras currently installed
nationwide and the government says they
are aiming to increase this to six
hundred million by 2020 but China's CCTV
system has a disturbing difference it is
powered by artificial intelligence CCTV
in China can recognize faces in a split
second and match it to a huge database
of over a billion people it can even
recognize what people are doing in real
time are they crossing the street
illegally are they arguing with someone
the camera knows and if it detects such
activity it can automatically deduct a
few points from that individuals social
credit score the cameras are able to
recognize license plate numbers and can
do the exact same for bad driving
behavior the social credit system is
also heavily entangled with Chinese
payment processors such as Ali pay who
have helped the government to develop
algorithms that can automatically adjust
an individual's social credit score
based on their spending behavior for
example if someone regularly purchases
beer that could indicate they are in
addict and so points will be deducted
points are also deducted for purchasing
too many video games video games and
beer account for a large portion of my
monthly expenditure so I would be
completely screwed whereas if a woman
purchases diapers it according to the
government is indicative of a
responsible personality and so their
social credit score will receive an
automatic boost and if an individual
marries someone with a lower social
credit score than themself it will pull
Laz down with it as you may imagine this
terrifying system crosses over to the
online world the Chinese government
monitors the social media posts and web
browsing activity of every one of its
citizens if they post anything negative
about China or the Communist Party then
their score is reduced
similarly any online activity that China
deems to be negative such as spamming
angry posting or simply visiting the
various web sites will put black marks
on people's records people with low
social credit ratings are named and
shamed in public large digital
billboards in shopping malls on train
stations show the faces names under
dress
of local residents with the lowest
scores there is even a mobile app that
shows the names and locations of anyone
with a low score in your vicinity
in real time whereas so-called model
citizens are venerated on local
information billboards in town squares
if the citizens social credit score
falls below a certain threshold they are
automatically placed on a blacklist
blacklisted individuals are banned from
purchasing train or aeroplane tickets
they cannot apply for a loan or rent a
flat they may not even be able to get a
phone contract and their social media
accounts are closed down they are
effectively forced out of society and
become prisoners within their own home
and they have usually not committed any
crime but the scariest part about
China's social credit system is not the
system itself but how the people of
China seem to be so openly accepting of
it whenever Western journalists
interviewed Chinese citizens all they
can do is rave about how much it has
improved their lives and community but
then speaking negatively about the
system itself is grounds for one school
to be severely reduced and Chinese
experts who have escaped the system tell
a completely different and more
dystopian story also the entire system
will naturally appear more totalitarian
to any Westerner because we are brought
up with genuine liberties and an
individualist mentality whereas China
has a history of the state ruling with
an iron fist and the people are raised
in a collectivist mentality where the
state is prioritized over any one person
whether or not a social credit system
would ever be implemented in the West is
unknown for the sake of basic human
rights let's all hope it isn't but the
amount of data you voluntarily hand over
to Silicon Valley companies each and
every day means they have enough of a
digital portrait of who you are to turn
on a social credit system
Morrow if they or the government desired
Google knows your movements what you
search for and what kind of videos you
like to watch a Facebook knows who your
friends and family are the websites you
visit your likes and dislikes your hopes
and fears a Google Apple or Facebook
knows your exact spending habits
depending on whether or not you have
linked your bank card to any of their
services and this is just scratching the
surface using complex AI driven
algorithms these companies are able to
data-mine facts about you that you may
not even know about yourself they can
predict when women are pregnant based on
their recent purchases sometimes before
the mother knows
they can predict where you are going on
a holiday before you even think about
booking it
but of course China differs
ideologically from the West China uses
all this personal data to give the state
greater control over the people whereas
the US and most of Europe uses that very
same data to sell people products which
I guess is slightly better than putting
people in the world's largest open-air
prison as some journalists have equated
China with recently you may have noticed
how so-called personalized ads follow
you around the web if you watch a video
on YouTube about the latest smartphone
you'll be bombarded with ads about that
phone for the next week
today ads can get creepily specific
advertisers can choose to target
overweight female cat owners who live on
a particular street are aged between 50
and 54 and have a secret crush on Phil
Collins if they want to all because of
the data that those targets freely gated
companies such as Facebook Google and
Apple but believe it or not this is only
the tip of the iceberg over the next
decades advertising is going to become
more targeted towards you and more
seamlessly integrated throughout your
daily life it will get to the point
where you won't know what is and is not
an advertisement as you walk through
town on your way to work
Green's and shop windows will show you
advertisements that only you can see
everyone else around you will see
something completely different on the
same screen personalized for them only
if you ate Brand X cereal at morning
then the advertisement will know that
and suggest up tomorrow
you try brand y cereal instead
furthermore your SmartWatch will pick up
on subtle biometric clues to learn how
you felt about the third verse wherever
you responded to it positively or
negatively this information will be
automatically unsilent li relayed to big
tech so they know whether or not to show
you that advert or similar adverts again
in the future
adverts will no longer be about what you
want and desire but they will be based
on your emotions and how you feel from
day to day from minute to minute your
wearable smart tech will likely be able
to tell when you're having a good day
and when you're feeling a bit down in
the dumps your mood will affect the
advertising you receive in real time if
you're feeling upbeat and outgoing you
may receive adverts for local theatre
shows but if you're in no mood to go out
that evening you'll more likely receive
ads for a new film you can rent on your
Smart TV perhaps right next to another
ad for the local pizza takeout but what
if your data is used for more than
advertising what caught a dystopian
political system do with all that data
to make your life otally miserable
you've already heard about the horrors
of China's social credit system but
could it come to the west and could it
get any worse
unbelievably yes the first way that your
data could and is being used against you
is in the court system eyewitness
testimonies are fraught with issues
they have been proven to be unreliable
by numerous studies but what is
extremely reliable is your digital data
police are increasingly using data
collected from people's phones and
various smart devices to collect
evidence for a court case recently a
woman in Pennsylvania accused a man of
raping her during her sleep but when
police examined the data logs of her
Fitbit it revealed that she had been
awake and walking around at the time
when she reported the rape happened so
instead of the man being charged the
woman was charged with false reports
through law enforcement false alarms to
Public Safety and tampering with
evidence had it not been for her Fitbit
she may have gotten away with it but
what if a chinese-style social credit
score came to the west well perhaps it's
already here the banks and various
finance companies already use a tried
and tested credit scoring system to
decide whether or not to lend an
individual money but it's fairly
one-dimensional it checks your address
history your voting record and how good
you have been at paying back loans in
the past but there's a new credit
reference agency in town lender lendo is
a Singapore based company that currently
only operates in emerging economies such
as Mexico the Philippines and Colombia
but it's testing the waters for
profitability but if it is a more
profitable model and the traditional
credit score industries then it will be
difficult to stop it from entering the
US and European markets instead of
looking at your borrowing history lendo
analyzes your social circle it looks at
who you're friends with what they do for
a living their hobbies and behaviors the
idea is that if you surround yourself
with a circle of what some people may
refer to as lowlifes then you yourself
are less likely to be financially
responsible and pay back your loan and
you will receive a low credit score but
if your Friendship Circle consists of
doctors and lawyers who play golf at the
weekend then you will get top marks and
the great credit score as this kind of
social Big Data
continues to enter the world of
financial tech it's going to get harder
and harder to tell the difference from
what China is doing right now but
however data is used in the coming
decades to control and coerce the
population those who will suffer the
greatest are today's youth the next
generation everyone who spent the
majority of their childhood in the
previous millennium the pre 2000 US only
began using social media after they hit
adulthood so most of the data they have
entered into the ominous cloud was
during their post teen years and that's
the big deal because the vast majority
of data never disappears you can look
back at your tweets Facebook posts and
email some over 10 years ago even if you
delete your accounts they usually remain
on a server somewhere in the world
always lurking in the background of your
life the age at which you began posting
online makes all the difference to how
much your data can be used against you
for one simple reason we are all totally
moronic when we are teenagers when
you're 30 not 15 you think you know
everything and each and every social
media post you make is a masterpiece for
the masses and then you reach your 20s
look back at all those posts and
painfully cringe at your former self and
now social media and the Internet has
become such an intrinsic part of society
that it's almost impossible for a child
to grow up without being somewhat
immersed in it teenagers today live
their entire childhood online every
notion conversation and movement they
make from child to young adult and
Beyond is logged in the data sphere for
eternity
so unlike the previous generation
today's youth will grow up with an
encyclopedias worth of embarrassing and
damning material that they or anyone
else can look back on with a simple
internet search this will and is already
being used again
then they may already be tainted for
life some health insurance companies are
reportedly looking back at the entire
history of people's social media to
check if they have ever posted about or
alluded to mental health issues and even
if they made one negative tweet ten
years ago about their mental state
they could be refused health insurance
or charged a hefty premium research has
revealed that at least 70% of employers
use social media to screen job
candidates you could be refused a job
simply because you made a post that
could have been construed as racist when
you were 14 even though that person was
a mere shadow of the person you are now
as an adult and the scariest part is
that this screening process has become
completely automated using AI it's
happening right now
a handful of startups have developed
such algorithms and already have
services online that employers can use
to do a comprehensive social background
check on anyone simply by typing in
their name the report will even include
a computer-generated trust score now
doesn't that just remind you of China's
social credit score all this just
scratches the surface of what is
possible using your data and it's only
going to get more intense and more
controlling as algorithms improve and
data treasure troves grow deeper over
the coming years it has been said that
data is the new oil and I can easily
believe that more legislation may be
needed to transfer the ownership of data
from corporations to the individuals who
provide it but until or if that ever
happens it's down to you and you alone
to protect your own data and decide
whether it's really that essential to
post a photo of your latest omelettes
online because five years down the road
you may be scrambling to wipe your
record clean you can easily limit your
exposure online and improve your
security and privacy with dashlane who
have kindly sponsored this video - lean
is a password
manager and security tool to help you
take the first steps towards taking
control of your data using the same or
similar passwords for different websites
makes it super easy for hackers to
access your entire online world but
dashlane creates unique super strong
passwords for all of your accounts and
also fills them so you never have to
click forgot password ever again
that's Lane also Auto fills your credit
card information whilst online shopping
so you can make purchases without having
to fetch your wallet it has a built-in
VPN with country select so you can
access any Content stay secure and
protect your privacy all at the same
time we've - Lane you'll be alerted if
any of your accounts or data are
breached and it also has a dark web
monitoring system that will immediately
let you know if your personal
information appears on the dark web
where it can be seen by hackers and
spammers but wait is this safe what if -
Lane gets hacked well it's actually
safer to put all of your passwords into
- Lane than if not using a password
manager - Lane safely stores and decrypt
your data on your local device only
using your master password
this means that - Lane never has access
to your personal data and in the rare
instance that a hacker did breach - Lane
they would only see random noise unlike
keychain chrome facebook login or /
logging tools that eva lock you into a
single system trapping your information
in one place or misuse your data to sell
ads - Lane works seamlessly across all
your devices and believes so strongly in
data privacy that they commit to always
being an ad-free product from my
experience - Lane is the best all bases
covered security and time-saving tool
out there and if you visit my unique
promo link in the description you can
get a free premium trial of - Lane for
30 days plus if you enter 40 to it check
out you will get 10% off dust Lane
premium thanks for watching and thanks
again to dust Lane for sponsoring this
video don't forget to check them out
using the link below